good morning Hank it's Wednesday and I'm
vlogging while biking Hank it's another
beautiful day here in Indianapolis I'm
loafing at my ease observing some Spears
of summer grass you did totally blow my
mind on Monday with that hole size of
the universe video thing and now I am
totally going to blow your mind by
discussing how Powe structural literary
analysis led to what Michele Foucault
famously called the insurrection of
subjugated knowledge 'as okay I figure
Hank probably turned off the video
around the foot in Foucault but Hank if
by some miracle you're still watching
even after hearing me quote Foucault
pluralizing the word knowledge first I
commend you and second I ordered you to
stop watching this video immediately
seriously Catherine make him stop
watching now
now other nerdfighters for the first
time in more than three years we are
free from the tyranny of Hank okay so
listen in two weeks it will be May 5th
aka Hanks 30th birthday aka Hank oh my
oh that's right we are a mere two weeks
away from the 30th and hopefully
best-ever Hank Oh DeMaio and we got to
get ready
so recently during a live show I was
asking nerdfighters what they thought we
should get Hank for his 30th birthday
and we were all completely flummoxed
because the problem with Hank is that he
doesn't really like anything he likes
ideas but it's not like you can get
someone the scientific method for their
birthday but then we realized that Hank
does like oxygen so here's what we're
gonna do we're going to come together
and as a community the nerdfighters are
going to plant trees and plants for Hank
which we will call Hank trees and Hank
plants even though they will not be made
of Hank so if you can plant a seed or a
tree sapling or some plants on Hanks
behalf and then photograph or videotape
yourself doing that and then email those
photos and videos to me at sparks fly up
at gmail.com and in all of us we'll be
in a huge vlogbrothers hank tree
planting video your deadline is May 3rd
please include your location and the
number of plants or trees you planted in
your email to be clear I'm not saying
that you plant the trees inside your
email I'm saying that you tell me how
many trees you planted inside you know
grammar oh and if you want to upload a
video for Hanks birthday on May 5th let
me encourage you to do so but let me
also encourage you to use corn dogs as
birthday cakes
Hank likes corn dogs in a related story
hmm damn that's right we are making a
sequel to the pizza shirt Hanks corn dog
shirt the Hank shirt will be available
for pre-order for one week and one week
only and that it'll ship
like three weeks so if you want to get a
corn dog shirt you can order one there's
a secret link in the dooblydoo half my
proceeds from the corn dog shirt will go
to planting trees where there used to be
trees but there are trees anymore but
there should be trees again and the
other half will go to supplement a bank
account I have recently set up to allow
nerdfighteria to buy Hank
30 presents for his 30 years that's our
first present bearing in mind that those
presents must be what's a nice word for
cheap inexpensive please leave your
suggestions in comments and I will pick
29 of them sometimes I find myself
wanting to do vlogbrothers voiceover
like the old man looks funny when he
points at his pants so that's what we're
gonna do for the 30th I go to my oh
please take pictures and video of
yourself planting trees and plants if
you don't have a yard where you can
plant such things you can always plant
them in a container garden
nerdfighteria let's give Hank what he
wants more than anything a higher
overall oxygenation level of the planet
I will try to answer any questions you
have in the comments thank you for being
awesome it is a pleasure to spend time
with you songs Hank to the puppy-sized
elephant my puff is a forest